can we please address the ghost thing oh
that's that's where yeah that's what was
most appalling let's talk about the
ghost forty-two percent of americans
believe in ghosts thirty-six percent
believe in UFOs twenty-nine percent
believe in astrology twenty-six percent
believe in witches twenty-four percent
believe in reincarnation that that does
seem very high to me forty-two percent
believe in goes bananas that's bananas
how paranoid are these people like their
allotted how you don't believe why don't
even go ever know never had experienced
any kind of experience or the great
experiences where I thought like okay
when I was younger like there's a ghost
in the house weird things are happening
but it was probably like the wind or an
open window or an open window or
something like that I don't know it's
just I just lose faith in our entire
democratic process when I realize that
these are the people that get to vote
these are the people they get to make
decisions about which politicians to
elect which representatives to elect in
the meantime they're worried about
ghosts forty-two percent of them okay
well but it will you a ghost story in a
second and they have to rethink that the
ghosts were real then there would be
hundreds of thousands of ex-slaves
haunting the crap out of the people the
families that enter that'd oppressive
there would be six and a half million
Jews just annoying Germans all around
the world there would be Native
Americans showing up at every door like
boo our place get out the idea that it
could be is blown out of the water by
any any rational thinking about what
that would entail right but I guess this
whole thing is based in not being
rational it's based in not it's taking
that leap if it's the same thing is the
belief in God in a way because the
people that say they saw a ghost are are
choosing to believe that it was it goes
just as the person that believes in God
is making the conscious or unconscious
choice feel like look I obviously don't
believe in ghosts but I feel like I'm
being really unfair to people who do
believe in God who do believe in
religion who do believe in ghosts
for me I believe that it's a coping
mechanism right so I think about someone
in my family I'm not gonna say who but
she lost other family members when she
was younger and her way of coping with
that loss was the belief that at one
point after her life is over she will
reunite and reconnect with those people
every time she's having a bad day and
then she dreams about those people that
she lost she thinks that that some sort
of sign from God you know that that
she's reconnecting with them on some
deeper level so III think that there is
a positive purpose for religion for the
people that do believe in God do believe
in an afterlife it's a coping mechanism
but with that said it's still bananas
because there's absolutely no proven
hide it so it's like you qualify that
for a little yes it's not not that harsh
not ready a piece and I want to see 20
years ago have I mentioned I'm much
older than you to come here I read if
he's a long time ago about the origin of
the ghost mythology and the idea that as
the human brain was developing there was
a point at which you're building a
homestead and throughout your childhood
dad is saying go fix the fence you got
to go check the fence and fix the fence
make sure the fence is okay and then dad
dies and you wake up one morning and you
sort of hear a voice in your head saying
go fix the fence you got to go figure Oh
dad is around because we had no better
way to interpret the the introjection of
people who are dead and I think that
makes perfect sense but there's also a
point what you have to go oh I see
that's an interjection of the people who
are dead that's I see how that is useful
to me I see how I get to still feel the
warmth that I felt toward people who are
no longer here but there's no ghosts
well I would be remiss that if I didn't
tell you my ghost story really quick I
was at a friend's house about five years
ago who lives in New Jersey in an old
home that was you know it's probably a
hundred fifty years old or something and
it's a little creaky and you know all
made out of wood and fireplaces and that
type of you know American Horror Story s
house very nice house so great guy uh
that was good it's been out of wooded
fire boys it's a try to really pay this
autumn around it's not saying it's not a
taco yeah and i was i was sleeping in
the guest room and his uh girlfriend at
the time had her vanity mirror in there
i guess that's where she did her makeup
and i woke up in the middle of the night
and i looked in the mirror and I saw an
old woman combing her hair slowly in the
mirror and then I did this and I check
my eyes and everything and then she
looked at me and then disappeared now I
don't know no when you take mushroom
okay so we we had smoked a little pot
but I've you don't usually hallucinate
on pot Jenna hot pot you're smoking it
was jersey breed pie another great my
look so I'm not saying I believe in it
or not yes did I maybe just wake up and
I was in this weird house and I saw that
I don't know so as a and I believe or
not but I can understand how someone
would have the exact same experience
that I had and say well now I believe
what's weird about that is that is the
whole is it my grandmother yeah told me
many years ago that she had been at a
place in New Jersey and she was combing
her hair in the middle of the night and
she looked into the mirror and there was
an attractive young man very briefly
rubbing his eyes and then he went to
sleep she was this a house that was
built from what if that would